c'est officiel montigny le bretonneux la
12e villes du département se voir
décerner le label ville amie des enfants
une distinction accordée par l'unicef le
fonds des nations unies pour l'enfance
et deux parties ont signé la charte ce
mercredi 31 mai au square du poirier
saint martin lee addy fiche spéciale à à
renseigner sur le handicap sur la façon
de vivre sur la santé sur l'éducation
dans le dossier de montigny je crois que
ce qui fait la différence ce qui fait
que on peut accepter montini comme ville
amie des enfants c'est qu'à travers ce
dossier on voit la solidarité que vous
exprimez la ville par rapport aux aux
enfants par rapport aux enfants de
toutes les races de toutes les cultures
j'irai enfin enfin la politique menée
par la ville de montigny en direction de
leur enfance et reconnu à son juste
niveau
pour rappel que nous travaillons bien
sûr ceci des politiques est là depuis
très très longtemps sur le terrain ce
partenariat va permettre de réaliser des
journées de sensibilisation comme ce fut
le cas avec les unis dès ce mercredi
l'événement organisé par le conseil des
jeunes de la ville et l'unicef a permis
à travers des jeux et des panneaux
informatifs d'expliquer les droits des
enfants
l'enfant apprend à travers les jeux
l'enfant à travers apprend à travers le
fait d'être en bonne santé de savoir
avoir les notions d'hygiène nécessaires
l'importance de la vaccination pour
éviter les les maladies l'importance
d'aller à l'école pour apprendre mais
pour apprendre le devenir de deux des
nations de comment progresser dans la
vie pour ne peut pas progresser sans
éducation
le label ville amie des enfants est
valable jusqu aux prochaines élections
municipales de 2020
montigny-le-bretonneux devra alors
constituer un dossier pour prolonger
l'aventuré avec l'unicef